there we go hi my name is Donna Yates
and I as previously said stated there we
go I'm from the University of Glasgow to
explain myself a little bit in the few
minutes that I have I am an
archaeologist but for the past four
years I have been working in a
criminology Department with the
previously mentioned trafficking culture
project and our goal has actually been
to approach some of the very questions
that Alison just named conveniently
enough to apply criminological and
sociological frameworks and analytical
techniques to try to understand the
trafficking of antiquities and also to
try to understand what's gone wrong with
policy and how we can make policy better
and that's what I'm going to focus on
for my seven minutes is what's gone
wrong with policy and potentially how we
can make it better so obviously we've
heard this today we looting has been a
long-term projects throughout the world
in a variety of places not just conflict
zones it's come back in the news
recently again and this kind of keeps
happening we kind of see the same
patterns over and over and over again
and yet the policy response we tend to
have at a high level and even at a local
level repeats the same kind of structure
that we've had for the past 40 years
clearly it doesn't work our policy tends
to be reactive it's not proactive we
craft policy in response two major
problems essentially we're trying to put
spilt milk back in a cup instead of
preventing the cup from falling over in
the first place our policy doesn't
actually tend to address the practical
realities of this type of illicit
commodity we tend to craft policy that
requires us to know exactly which
country and artifact came from after
exactly what date and there's an example
feeding from UNSCR 2199 iraq since six
august 99 to syria since 15 march 2011
but if you've just discovered say this
figurine in New York can you tell what
country it came from can you tell when
it left the country can you prove it can
you prove it in a court of law if you
can't that objects not going back and
you can
pretty much never prove it our pocket
policy tends to focus on supply not just
policy i'm talking about intervention
and response rather than focusing on
demand and demand cause a supply
artifacts are looted because people will
buy them and at this point most of our
national and international policy should
be focusing on demand and reducing
demand but it doesn't and if i was going
to give a longer talk today i would go
very much into why this this kind of sub
supply focus policy doesn't work but
seven minutes really it is exceedingly
hard to craft high-level policy that
takes into account all of the
intricacies of all of the developing
world all the developed world all the
source countries all of the market yet
for in a lot of respects the developing
source countries are our first line of
defense when it comes to preventing the
illicit trafficking of objects
assumptions are made about logistical
capabilities of these countries and they
don't often reflect on the ground
reality yet again this is our first line
of defense and as we've seen again in a
number of different presentations if the
objects leave the country is very
unlikely that they will ever return I'll
skip over that skip over that again
longer talk if you guys would like to
see it but these these really big issues
come up and I'll go through so the de
burden on developing countries so as I
said the current international
regulatory regime depends on on the
ground policing and developing countries
this is a huge financial burden and it's
a disproportionate financial burden
there's a requirement for qualified
staff sufficient and number that again
doesn't reflect reality the result is
policy that is extremely difficult to
enforce on the ground due to financial
shortfalls in institutional failure and
the expectation that source country
should be the primary policing line for
the prevention of the trafficking of
Antiquities I say may prevent but
really does prevent the apprehension of
criminals who are higher up on the
antiquity smuggling network and doesn't
really reflect breaking up these
networks and certainly doesn't reflect
reducing market demand we focus on
countries not objects like I said the
international regulatory system requires
on countries working in partnership
often two countries even though it might
be a multi-country country networking
network of antiquities trafficking and
as traffic objects pass through several
other states they may go through
jurisdictions that don't have a vested
interest in preventing trafficking and
as I previously stated the country of
origin of many objects can't be
determined anyway another issue that has
come up in a previous talk is that
cultural objects are not necessarily the
only things that are the culture of the
trafficking of cultural objects are
connected to other crimes the same
people who engage in various types of
subsistence looting subsistence
trafficking in big engage in other
illicit anona lists at subsistence
economies and our decisions made to
regulate those objects may actually
affect the regulation and the prevention
of antiquities trafficking but very
little work has been done on this so we
don't know much about it so what would
bold new policy and tail just because
the system is embedded good just because
the system is embedded doesn't mean that
we have no other options in trying to
envision bold new policy we on the
trafficking culture project over the
past four years based off of our field
research have come up with several
things on first object focused inch
portrait restrictions should be promoted
this idea that we can that we must
identify the country of origin of
objects or the date that it left a
certain country simply doesn't work and
I'll get to that in a second we need to
target traffickers and buyers not on the
ground looters and we don't need to
waste too much time and effort on a
limited
number of an expensive high-profile
returns at the expense of not actually
going after traffickers and buyers and
to do this we need evaluation because
quite frankly we don't know what works
we keep implementing the same policy but
it isn't effectively evaluated or tested
and we need to accept those results we
need to borrow on successes because
antiquities aren't that special when it
comes to the trafficking of illicit
commodities and there have been quite
some good policy successes for curbing
say the trafficking of ivory or
rhinoceros horns so one obvious example
of something we can do is have a
universal permitting system for the
movement of Antiquities in art there the
UNESCO offers a model permit that's
great but you can own the countries can
decide if they're going to adopt that we
had an international system again much
like we have for wildlife it would be
exceedingly difficult to fake that
previously said objects not origin dates
and this is something you'll hear all of
us on the traffic and culture projects I
over and over again is we need to focus
on market reduction just because there
is a market for something doesn't mean
that it's a valid commodity and we don't
have to accept that antiquities are
valid commodities on the market and this
goes into a lot of our research that I
could talk about excellent about white
collar crime and so on and so forth but
we do need to radically regulate and
radically reduce the market and there
are ways to do that and this will anger
people but we should be prepared for
that and I will end it there thank you
very much and everyone can have lunch
now
thank you